نقص واضح في رفوف الخضروات لاسيما الخيار
والطماطم في هذا المتجر يتكرر المشهد ذاته
في المتاجر الاخرى ماذا دفع عددا من
المستهلكين الى تعويضه ولو باسعار عاليه
في مثل هذه السوق الشعبيه الشرقيه
الامر يختلف من يوم لاخر واعتقد ان البعث
يشترون كل شيء بالجمله ونحن نحصل على ما
هو متوفر لديهم ولان هناك نقصا في الخيار
في البلاد فهذا ينعكس ايضا على السوق
[تصفيق]
هو اربعين في المئه من احتياجاتها من
الخضروات من دول في شمال افريقيا وجنوبي
اوروبا وتلقي الحكومه باللوم في نقص
الامدادات على سوء احوال الجو في هذه
الدول تقول الحكومه انا نقص الخضروات ازمه
مؤقته ستنفرج خلال اسابيع لكن يبدو ان
تطميناتها لا تجد صدى لها لدى المزارعين
الذين لم يعد بعضهم قادرا على الانتاج
بيوت زجاجيه فارغه على غير عادتها في مثل
هذا الوقت من السنه صاحبها توني شانه شانه
الكثيرين من امثاله يقول ان الانتاج لم
يعد مجديا اقتصاديا في فصل الشتاء امام
اسعار الطاقه القياسيه
بسبب ازمه الطاقه فانني سازرع متاخرا في
هذا الموسم بغرض توفير تكاليف الطاقه
ولكنني بذلك سانتج اقل وهذا يؤثر على ما
ازود به الاسواق
ليس الا الجزء الظاهر من ازمه يعتقد البعض
ان احد مسبباتها
الامر اكثر صعوبه بالنسبه للمنتجين
البريطانيين في الحصول على العماله
الرخيصه وهذا دفعهم الى تعديل كميه ما
يمكن انتاجه بالنظر الى التكاليف
[موسيقى]
ان المتاجر الكبرى تهيمن على نحو
95% من تجاره تجزئه المواد الغذائيه في
بريطانيا فانها تستخدم قوتها الاقتصاديه
لفرض شروط صعبه على المزارعين بدعوى تقديم
اسعار متدنيه للمستهلكين لكنها في المقابل
تضعف قدرات المزارعين وتدفع كثيرين منهم
خارج السوق من حرب اللغه الجزيره لندن